okay so we start with the the cream
cheese is already in there so we're
gonna start with the sour cream
and just get cheese base sour cream on
top it's just like a beautiful dairy
balm i was just gonna say i already love
this dish so much it's so tasty it's
like i don't know if anyone who's
watching has ever really had kugel it's
a jewish dish but it's like a delicious
like noodle
sweet pie i don't know
sweet noodle pie sweet noodle pie like
doesn't that just sound so good yes and
then we oh my god this is so heavy we
put the eggs and this is like all the
wet ingredients together it's like eggs
vanilla
something else i don't remember and you
just pour that right in if you go to our
website the full recipe from cindy penny
and joey will be on it it is the famous
coogle yes so fancy schmancy let me try
okay then we're gonna go with our
cottage cheese i personally unless it's
in this cocoa i'm not a huge cottage
cheese lover i love it my mom raised me
on it california 1970s the pink knutson
carton i it's like pavlovian for me
[Music]
it really is you're just gonna like fold
that in like whisk it up a little bit
and remember like how that was like the
business woman's diet special like i'll
have half a grapefruit with some cottage
cheese
you know cherry on top okay so this is
all mixed in it's good we can throw this
on top of our egg noodles and my cousin
cindy made sure to tell me to tell your
producers to get full fat everything you
can't go like two percent or anything
like healthy alternatives with this if
you're making kegel you just gotta
really lean into the
um
just the everything
all right okay so we're gonna do that
and then
i can't remember she's gonna be so mad
if i sprinkle the cinnamon and sugar
before or after these before yeah it's
before okay so we're gonna sprinkle this
on i will do before yeah today we'll do
before cindy if that's wrong oh i sort
of went on top should i mix together i
mean you know it's your kuggle whatever
you want to do i don't know
it's my kugo and i can it's my cool i
can cry if i want to
this is going to be so tasty and then
we're done i mean it's the easiest thing
to make you just kind of just chuck it
in the oven and then the magic of
television and then yeah what we're
going to do is put it in time and temp
by the way oh dear i know that's a heavy
dish time and temp on the coogle
you're going to go top i'll go like how
long in the oven what temperature i
don't know did i write that down i can't
remember it'll be on the website oh gosh
so oh my god look it's ready how did
that happen
oh my god it's amazing
[Applause]
350 degrees for about 20 minutes that's
what i said
that's why i knew that um and this is so
exciting i've always wanted to do like a
cooking segment on a show what started
you on your instagram journey of like
putting all your cooking on there um my
boyfriend is an amazing cook really
amazing and so he really got me into
cooking and then once i started i just
could not stop cooking's the best it's
so like fun it's therapeutic i like the
amount of time it takes and i'm going to
take my dairy pill
now we've turned into a couple of old
ladies i'm like
pills honey you know where's our
knitting needles let's go i know
there's your water darling before we eat
the google
[Laughter]
oh my god you are me
[Applause]
you made me laugh while i was inhaling
water
um
we're gonna just be here all day like
this people are like
huh and then
and then you just chow down i also like
cooking because i like to eat also like
i might have to do the ghost thing with
you with the cocoa
as promised
[Applause]
so this is
this is cindy's famous coogle and if you
look under your seats i'm just kidding
um
there's a
i'm
cougar
that's not true um no that's not true i
mean
i don't mean to be creepy but could i
please give you my phone number
yeah please i would love that i need to
keep laughing with you can i give you
mine yes
[Applause]
i've always loved you so much
um thank you so much for coming on this
show by the way the in in-between is
available to stream tomorrow
on paramount
[Applause]
[Music]